hello i'm dillard
and i'll be talking about my project
called radiation threats to humans and
space and an alternative approach with
probiotics a project i conducted during
my time at the omix logic research
fellowship program
and i chose to study ionizing radiation
among the different types of space type
radiation because it can penetrate cells
and cause chemical reactions or
mutations
scientists in the iss are exposed to
copious amounts of radiation especially
during longer stays that are over six
months
one way the effects of radiation can be
studied is through the microbiome since
our gut microbiota has effects on our
brains and other organs to study this
the species of bacteria and the samples
have to be identified and the best line
best pipeline for otu analysis is data
too
and following that i conducted phyloseq
analysis
using the t bioinfo platform and to
confirm my results from these outputs i
also performed a t test and an innova
test my dataset included 80 samples of
species collected from mice exposed to
radiation
they were divided into categories of
days and doses there were two categories
for days 10 days and 30 days
and four categories four doses
zero gy 0.1 gui 0.25 gy and one gui
in the output we generate a shannon
index graph that helps us gauge the
effective number of street feeds
here in the results as you can see
0.1 and 0.25 gy at 10 days has a
decrease e and s
from the final genetic tree the same
results can be reiterated
to confirm these results i conducted a
t-test in anova test and the results
indicated that for otu c4 5 and 8 at 0.1
gy at 10 days there is a lower there are
lower amounts
than the control group
then to find which species these ots
belong to and how they interacted with
the nervous system i use jgi website to
identify my otus and they belong to the
lactobacillus and by for the bacterium
species
genius
these two species have protein choline
genes in the gabaergic pathway gaba is
gamma aminobutyric acid
which is the chief neurotransmitter in
the central nervous system and has
effects on depression and anxiety
since the enterodaenertic nerve and the
vagus nerve connect the gut to the brain
we can presume that lactobacillus and by
from the bacterium decrease will cause a
decrease in gaba
in return and might be a factor in
depression of course more research
needs to be conducted with long-term
exposure to radiation and synergetic
effects of microgravity and radiation to
conclusively suggest a relationship
a solution could be probiotics rich in
lactobacillus and by for the bacteria
and i think this research is important
important
since this is this
new era a continuation
of
the space
age and
the landing of perseverance in the past
months
has uh
confirmed this so i think more research
has to be conducted
in uh outer space
regarding radiation in microgravity
so thank you for listening to me and i
would like to thank my mentors ilia
brodsky harp recorder and mohit musamdar
for all of their help
thank you